Here are the nominees for
Performance by an Actor
in a Supporting Role.
When I heard my name called,
for the first time in my life
I kind of felt like time
stopped for a moment.
I felt like I was
in this like vortex.
Mahershala Ali, Moonlight.
This is the first Oscar and
nomination for Mahershala Ali.
It was one of the most special
things I've ever experienced.
Just to see so many people out
there that I admire and love
and appreciate and
am inspired by,
by clapping for me
and for our film.
I still can get
choked up about it.
So yeah, I'm a little
speechless now.
This is how I felt, speechless.
Wow.
I managed to find
some words to say.
I just want to thank my wife
who was in her third trimester
during awards season.
We just had our
daughter four days ago.
Don't get pregnant
during awards season
and don't get your partner
pregnant during awards season.
It's already crazy so you don't
want to add babies to that.
I just want to thank
her for being just such
a soldier through this process
and help in really carrying me
through it all so, thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Peace and blessings.
I was amazed and
in awe of it all.